democrats say they're not giving up the
fight over the supreme court appointment
even though
only two republican senators have said
the vote should wait
as nancy cordes reports gop leadership
is confident they can fill that vacancy
quickly we've got the votes to confirm
justice ginsburg replacement before the
election senator lindsey graham the
chairman of the judiciary committee
says there will be a vote before
november 3rd
before that there will be a battle the
american people are about
to witness an astonishing parade of
misrepresentations
about the past i want the republicans
just to live up to their word
that word was the gop's claim in 2016
that a supreme court nominee should not
be confirmed in an election year
so they blocked president obama's pick
of course
the american people should have a say in
the court's direction
[Music]
the protests have already started
democrats fear a more conservative court
would overturn the affordable care act
and roe versus wade
the stakes of this vacancy concern no
less
than the future of fundamental rights
for the american people democratic vp
nominee kamala harris
could find herself called back to
capitol hill in the closing weeks of the
campaign
whoever is elected should be making a
decision about who sits on the united
states supreme court
period period
that's how it should be with voting
already underway
in some states two republicans want the
party to wait
a third republican utah's mitt romney
wouldn't say where he stands yet
but it would take four republicans to
block a vote
and last night colorado's cory gardner
announced
he will vote to confirm a qualified
nominee graham who like gardner is
facing re-election
said republicans would not back down
they're not going to intimidate me mitch
mcconnell or anybody else
i'm getting outraged 3-1 outspent 4-1
if you want to help me fight back go to
lindsey graham.com
5 or 10 bucks from half your audience
would fill in the gap that i'm facing
graham's plea for money there highlights
a risk for
republicans just a few minutes after
corey gardner
announced his support for a vote for
instance his
senate campaign can opponent began
trending
on twitter as thousands of dollars began
pouring into his campaign coffers gail
nancy thank you very much